i need to know what have you watched
jojo it's my passion my love in life
i'm afraid to say no
cancel the episode oh my god cancel it
move on and move on in the
you dare
sit behind and call yourself a
delinquent
and jojo practically invented
delinquents i'm pretty sure before jojo
there was no there was no delinquents
before joe escape bro
pay your respect okay the god of
delinquents
he's actually a very nice guy and helps
the community out so he's holly at
lincoln no i'm kidding i think you would
love it though i think you'd like it a
lot yeah oh
wait wait wait um can i ask you this is
um
kishibe rohan a part of jojo yes indeed
he's in part four how do you know about
kishiba rohan oh
i've seen that before
i've read i've read that kishibe rohan
comics i know
yeah but i didn't know it was jokes you
watched the spin-off
it's just been awful it's just like
watching the like jar jar binks like web
comic
instead of watching star wars watching
the star wars christmas special before
star wars
you know i've i've heard of people
skipping parts
that's a whole new thing
with the rohingyas
skipping past which is meant to be the
biggest sin to any jojo fans what level
do we put just starting with the side
story
were you not confused
no
because that spin-off is confusing even
for fans because the episodes aren't in
the correct order characters just turn
up as well yeah like we know from prior
did you like it i i really liked it
you'll love jojo then you should go and
watch like proper like
but not the spin-off jojo i can't
believe i can't i can't look you in the
eye right now
something about your energy though says
that i think you'll really yeah
if you if you love the rohingya one you
will love jojo yeah yeah yeah because
rocky is just charging
yeah yeah so it's split up into parts
and then each of the different parts
have different protagonists they're
different main characters but kishiba
rohan's not a protagonist
he's he's the main character he's he is
a he's like an important sidekick very
important yeah he's a side character
that everyone loves yeah he's a side
character but he's not in any of the
ichiba nebu he's in he's in yonbo
yeah yeah like
i started from yombu kinda yeah
yeah you kind of started from in the
middle 0.5 yeah
is that a sin
i'm not i'm not pleased that you started
there how did you how did you even start
there how did that happen netflix
no um i read the jump comics oh
okay okay okay okay that means i thought
it makes a little more sense
to happen
we'll have a nice day
now you can go understandable but
unforgivable
oh my god i wish i could have watched
you reading it just to see like how
confused
what the [ __ ] is going on but i enjoyed
it it's fun i mean i really like the
rocky bear it's a great side story the
anime is amazing as well yeah i gotta
say i my favorite one did you did you
read all of the wrong giveaway ovas
or just some of them side story side
stories
i don't know i i i don't know the uh uh
i don't know there's one okay okay tell
me if this sounds familiar tell me this
sounds good
he goes to a gym
and there's a guy who he's running with
at the gym oh yeah
have you read this one
no i i love this one so god damn much i
love that one yeah it's just like
they know how to explain it he just goes
to the gym and starts racing against a
guy who then wants to then beat him wait
i know right right right right it's so
good this is like one of the this is
this does not get memed enough this bit
it's like peak jojo yeah have you seen
it yeah it's so good and then the guy's
obsessed with protein and then like oh
my god it's just so
i love this please watch the rohan ovas
if you like jojo you will love it just
watch jojo in general it's amazing it's
amazing yeah it's bad i'll start okay
but i'll i'll tell you the order you
have to watch it in so you start with
one
and then you go two and then two and
then you go three and three yeah and
then you go four then you can have
already broken that so yeah
rohan keesha based side story then part
nine probably
first chapter of part nine